this is the world's largest oil
processing plants located in the eastern
province of Saudi Arabia early on
Saturday September 14 a series of
explosions rocked the facility and the
world woke to see it burning satellite
images show thick black smoke billowing
from the Aramco oil facility in AB geek
the nation's state-run oil company Saudi
Aramco has temporarily closest
facilities which many experts expect
will cause a lack of supply leading to
higher global oil prices but while the
world was looking over here energy
traders on Wall Street and elsewhere
were also looking over here and here and
here at thousands of storage sites
around the world where companies and
countries stockpile oil what's inside
these tanks can be valuable information
for traders who make big bets based on
how much supply is available and where
in the world it's located for traders an
event like the one in Saudi Arabia can
be an opportunity so in the event of you
know market crisis situations or
disaster events there's a natural
increase in volatility and we do see
increase interest from our client base
and from prospective clients mario de la
Ossa is an energy specialist at orbital
insight a company that estimates the
tanks contents using satellite imagery
artificial intelligence and a lot of
complicated math I guess I say well we
are quite proud of our coverage levels
which are on the order of seeing about
80% of the world's oil tanks every week
orbital is at the vanguard of firms that
sell data to hedge funds energy
companies and others who are looking to
anticipate oil price moves to get their
hands on the data the first thing
orbital had to do was find as many of
these tanks as it could employees
trained computers to spot them by
feeding them image after image of oil
tanks once the computers got the picture
they scanned satellite imagery and found
more than 25 thousand tanks around the
world orbital is constantly collecting
images of each tank which its computers
then examine to estimate their contents
the keys are doing that lies in the
shadows particularly those cast upon the
tops of the tanks a floating roof tank
goes up and down according to the volume
of
oil that's inside of the tank and that's
done to prevent a vapor space performing
that would be very bad in terms of
explosion risks orbitals computers
measure the shadows cast on and around
the area of each tank the shadow casts
to the outside is used to determine the
size of each tank which can range from
fifty thousand barrels to more than a
million the shadow cast inside the
structure it's used to measure how much
oil is inside the tank generally the
bigger the shadow the less oil there is
inside so we have that going for us that
were the position of the roof is will
correspond to the volume of oil inside
of the tank but then to actually
calculate the specific volume this does
become a you know complex in terms of
aligning the exact position of the
satellite the position of the Sun to
adjust for the shadow link that was cast
orbital then adds up the volumes and
compares them over time noting when
stockpiles grow and shrink in different
regions the company is able to do this
quickly beating official reports by
weeks and sometimes even months and they
can offer insight to parts of the world
where supply data are scarce or suspect
so how much is there in let's say
Cushing Oklahoma and that's fairly well
tracked what's not fairly well tracked
and this is one of the big problems for
people in the market places how much oil
is in China because the Chinese don't
openly disclose that historically eighty
percent of the market has just been very
very dark knowing how much oil is out
there and where it's stockpiled is
useful to a range of businesses energy
producers use it to decide whether to
drill wells refiners that turn crude
into products like gasoline and jet fuel
want to know when to buy their main
ingredient hedge funds and other
speculators simply want to make money
these traders might act on clues that
stockpiles are dwindling by buying oil
now and selling it later once other
buyers realize supplies are low and the
price goes up predicting changes in the
availability and thus the price of oil
can be incredibly lucrative Andy Hall
who advises orbital is one of the most
successful and well-known oil traders of
recent decades he made a fortune buying
boatloads of cheap oil before Saddam
Hussein invaded Kuwait in 1990 which
touched off the first Gulf War and
crude prices soaring traders like Hall
are always looking for ways to gauge oil
supply they count the rigs that are
drilling wells and measure what's
passing through pipelines they train
cameras on import and export loading
docks and count tankers moving through
waterways like the Houston Ship Channel
and the Strait of Hormuz firms like
orbital have taken this kind of
detection to a whole new level before
the attacks on Saudi Arabia orbital
observed a lot of shrinking shadows on
the tops of the kingdom's oil tanks
suggesting that it was building up its
stockpiles but after the attacks the
shadows began to grow which meant that
Saudi Arabia was tapping reserves to
satisfy customers but the firm didn't
just look there it looked at China where
tanks were full and the US which were
also well stocked and in Japan and South
Korea which were not and in India where
the shadows were growing as imports from
Saudi Arabia dwindled meanwhile back on
Wall Street and in Houston and London
and Singapore traders placed their bets